i want to start with congratulations on
the movie i thought you guys did such a
great job i don't say that on every film
i promise um i i can't imagine what it
what it was like being a part of this
and getting to play this character and
being a part of this film um
who was the most excited of your friends
and family that you were like part of
this i always say my dad but now that
i'm thinking about it was my grandmother
that which makes more sense actually
you know what i mean she was like bb
king huh
yes indeed
and i was like yes indeed nana
yes indeed so it's been a real it's been
a it's been a real um honor and
privilege i would imagine when you're
getting ready to do a film like this
there's a lot of research you're going
through as much as you can to prepare
what was like one of the one or two
things that you learned either about bb
or elvis that really sort of floored you
floored me you know actually you know i
did not know about this whole colonel
tom parker
situation
and that was like baffling and i found
that that when i started reading the
script i was like wow what a one a
brilliant in to the story from baz
um and then two
what a tragic way to
to to find out this is was the decline
of elvis presley as we know him um
so those were the things but then also
the friendship between bb and elvis i
didn't know about that as well and i was
actually that was very uplifting to me
and very inspiring to see that
brotherhood to see that support of
artist artists um so there yeah those
were the two things i think that shocked
me the most i thought austin did such a
tremendous job
he's fantastic um what was it like for
you first time you saw him on set as
elvis and the transformation that he did
i heard about it two years before i even
got there because i was one of the last
i was in the last wave of the cast and
um i heard he was like prepping and
doing the voice and i was like so i was
anticipating this like really
beyond transformation and then i got
there and i was still blown away
and i was like okay yeah people say
they're doing this and i was like a lot
of actors like to go to the extremes and
you know it's just all for nothing you
know and then i see it and i was like
wow he's
managed to
fully take on the voice i mean we're
having jam sessions with yola an
incredible voice gary clark and shanka
and all these gospel singers from
memphis austin is singing with them as
elvis and i'm just like first of all do
you have to know that you've done it to
be able to have the confidence to do
that so it was um
i was really inspired by it all honestly
i was really proud of him and i was
really inspired to see the commitment
and how much fun he was having in that
space one of the things about the film
is that bez is his editing makes like
that's sort of his last thing that he
does to the movie and you can't read
that in the script the way it's going to
look on screen and i'm very curious what
it was like for you finally seeing his
vision come to life because you know the
editing is such a huge part of this film
and the way he is doing split screens
and the music you know what i mean well
you can kind of feel it i feel like i
can feel it when i'm shooting with him
you know and like he actually showed me
some stuff when i first got there before
i even started shooting because they had
already shot so much of the kernel like
um tom was done by the time i got to the
shoot so i got to see a little bit of
the world so i had a better idea of what
movie i was making um and i think it
also was very important to for us to
kind of come into it and know what is
the style of the performance that you're
giving you know because it's like the
conversation is like well how bb king do
we go and you know or how bb king in
baza's world do we kind of make it you
know is it about the spirit is it about
the the details is that elvis space or
is that my space as well you know so um
but also but still when you see it it
takes you on a full experience and you
just you ride the way if you put your
your safety belt on and you go on a
roller coaster i completely agree listen
again i want to say congrats on the
movie hope it's a huge hit for you guys
um thank you so much for giving me your
time
you